what was I voted most likely to in my  high school yearbook a to be president B  to end up in jail C to be on the quiz  show Jeopardy or D to be an Olympic  medalist  it's a toss-up but um president  no no no no no it's the third one yeah  because you know a lot of things  yes that gets that one right have you  ever had a chance to go on Jeopardy do  you want to go on like with you I have  not and I would definitely do it if I  was asked to do they have like they do  have like a version with people who are  like known who give their money to  charity and stuff that's you come on  thank you wait this is Tessa talking  people tell them wait let's get you on  there